I did yoga did come food it are all
kinds of things and and a great but the
cold is really merciless but righteous
I'm a man on a mission I want to take
away fair women teach me some briefing
right now show me some so I can
demonstrate it all right Juanes or get a
mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's learn from one
of the best wim hof and some of his best
life-changing advice mentor me wim
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
take control there scientist after
giving me and dr. seem virus bacteria
they saw I have no symptoms I can
control my fever I can control it all
through breathing and believing or the
mind using the mind plus breathing
suddenly I was able to suppress four
other students in all those controlled
studies all these other test subjects
didn't show those results of bringing
down these flama Tory markers and
showing to be able to go into the
endocrine system controlled and race
such a controlled adrenaline shootout
through their body making the body
being able to function to the utmost
completely under the will then bacteria
has no chance cult has no chance heat
has no chance stress in general has no
chance people who are under stress like
anxiety depression fear trauma PTSD name
it any mental mood disorder or mental
disorder is able now if we bring this on
through comparative study is done able
to counteract and not be a victim of the
stress or the out-of-control brain bring
back the sense of control make you feel
good thus this big demon is is just for
removing renumber to embrace the power
of your mind explain the mission why are
you doing this why it's so important to
you it's not just about setting the
world record so why do you do this yes
as I said
a lot of stuff outside in nature because
I felt this disconnection from nature
inside from soul itself soul is not able
to express and you can see it in the
world full of depression and out immune
diseases cancer all those things and
anxiety so nobody knows actually is
because of the disconnection of nature
so resulted in me and an awkward feeling
I don't know what there is but there is
more the meets the eye I'm going into a
soul search and that brought me to all
kinds of traditions as a tarik
disciplines languages religions debates
about philosophies cultures anything you
know but in the end it didn't connect
with me that's what the cold water came
in I had a cold water is merciless but
righteous okay so mum and you gotta be
there right but little by little you
begin to wake up to that what you feel
inside it's beginning to wake up a real
primordial this connection is beginning
to connect to your consciousness
brain-body connection and now after
doing 26 of those world records about
numerous war challenges got me gotten
encountered with scientists and then it
came about that I was awakening and
stimulating and influencing
with in demotic they thought of not
being able to be influenced or connected
with four humans they thought and humans
cannot happen
it's an autonomic nervous system an
autonomy care process outside of our
world but brain-body connection remember
connection there it is and now I am able
to connect enter and make the difference
and that's what I did in the studies
wins mission is to use his body as a
laboratory to revolutionize our
understanding of physiology in 2011 he
was injected with the bacterial
endotoxin in an experiment that
challenged our understanding of the
nervous system in normal humans the
injection should cause a strong immune
response leading to fever chills and
headaches but not and when it appeared
that he was somehow able to suppress his
immune response by making his body
secrete adrenaline suggesting that his
method can allow us to influence our
immune system at will scientists thought
he might just be a freak of nature so to
further prove this theory they performed
the same experiment on 12 subjects women
trained in Poland and the same thing
happened
Rufio only got after comparative study
with groups so I took on a full group I
trained him 48 to get into the autonomic
nervous system and all those things and
they got a administered with the
bacteria and as well all within a
quarter of our entering in those into
those systems and now we're getting
somewhere
power of the mind yeah we are dealing in
modern day society we can go to the
morning we can go to Mars and everywhere
but we cannot tap into the depth of
ourselves and make the difference for a
deep depression anxiety fear trauma PTSD
anything also if you want to have more
confidence checking my 254 series they
are free the link to join are in the
description below I believe you
that's what I would have said because I
they believe yes I believed in it rule
number three don't let fear stop you I
was there ever a time in your life where
you lost belief in yourself
whoa that many times I've encountered
almost you know death and then I'm
losing it how do you come back from that
tougher experience yes yes how do you
retrain your your body and mind is
believe in the next record the next
adventure
yeah are actually very quick an example
for example is the first time I had to
do a record with the Guinness World
Records swimming under the guys save 50
meters one hole here one hole there one
meter of ice and then breath-hold
freezing waters beyond the Polar Circle
situation and at the day before I had to
do the actual record and went in I had
no goggles on I lost away because I lost
a sight got frozen the cornea the retina
and I lost it I did 113 meters you
couldn't find the hole and I couldn't
find it all at
I almost know I in the end I fainted it
but I did not feel any agony and I felt
actually quite peaceful after minutes
and minutes are under the eye swimming
you exhaust your body and I got is this
narrowed vision boom just seeing that
that's physiological Wow and then I went
down swimming it was all okay was like I
was swimming into the death
unconsciousness
and that somebody grabbed me a diver and
he brought me back to the 50-meter Oh
which are you kept going past the hole
yeah yeah yeah completely off and then
it was the rehearsal so the diver was
are not underneath the ice he was still
up there but hey I was or four minutes
too much too long then they took me
under the ice wow that's a moment so how
did you come back from the how do you
train your mind to believe in yourself
again at that moment I actually had 100
I
I overcame the the fear of death I'm
dying
there was no agony that's strange
and that's past my perception of what I
thought it was death you know fear and
there's nobody wants to die is there
maybe it's much more beautiful out there
huh we're in the afterlife and now we
got a live eye ah trade to die I'm
afraid not to live you know quotes and
things but based on experience and so I
really defied death and the fearful
death over there not defying like I did
it know what happened and I learned from
it to take away my fear for death so and
then the other day I only had to do 50
meters which was Apple take a couple of
butterfly kicks and you're there huh
that's it came out happy yeah yeah okay
that was my number one I like it record
do you face fear now when you go into
some extreme challenge or in any part of
your life a good question any part of
the life because it's all about the life
and actually no my I'm a man on a
mission no fears no no no I'm a man on a
mission I want to take away fear you
know irrational fears traumatic fears
fears created because you do not handle
mental issues
nice grief emotion PTSD trauma
depression those things we are going to
tackle and somebody's got to do this and
I should have no fear to accomplish that
you know a man on a mission should not
think in me in fear you should go and
accomplish his mission yeah and be
focused so there I am I feel feel like
everybody because it's natural to mm-hm
you feel fear failures or you said don't
know I fear I feel you fear like
everybody but it doesn't hold you back
from moving for not come on man it's a
much too important rule number four
awaken your inner strength what is it
about what you do that triggers the
adaptation response and what adaptation
response does it trigger the power to
adapt to this stressor in general we
lost this connection is because we wear
clothes all the time and we live in a
comfort zone behavior we think we can
control nature but by being non
stimulative in our behavior we lost the
connection
in the depth of our physiology cause we
are able to adapt about to anything we
are built to be able to adapt without
stress into any stressful situation
again a solution the body knows but
because we got into this comfort zone
behavior hundreds of years our genetics
have changed our physiology has changed
everything has changed and we lost
actually the
full power of the mind and I'm here to
bring it back so how do we bring it back
I did many studies already because I
don't like the speculation I go through
study the scrutiny and let any scientist
prove me wrong because I like to go
through the truth because I think there
is more than meets the eye I did many
studies and yes I could resist a
bacteria as thought of not being able by
humans
we changed medical history by showing a
group of people compared to sixteen
thousand one hundred and thirty-four
people becoming sick after injection of
a endotoxemia and then suddenly twelve
hundred percent school within a quarter
of our complete control over the innate
immune system and is specific by the way
the adaptive immune system and how did I
learn to do that and pass it on because
it's already there in us it only needs
to awaken the finally adaptive immune
system the adaptive immune system is
willfully regulating and controlling
your t-cells and b-cells and they are
located in the bone marrow we are able
to willfully influence the bone marrow
and to release the T and beta B cells
which are very specific in the targeting
on the bacteria and the virus and
apoptosis cell death
they created instead of fever and
uncontrolled shivering and and headaches
and being sick flus fever and all that
is the second layer we got into the
third layer into the depth of the immune
system into the deepest so willfully
being able to get into the bone marrow
and release the T and B cells in case of
inflammation it's what we an
inflammation I tell you is the course of
any disease did you just say that you
can willfully control apoptosis yes
anybody can okay for that we have the
breathing exercises and it has a
shown in the comparative study all the
guys who did their breathing exercises
the endotoxin normally creates
inflammation and thus uncontrolled
shivering all over agony headaches and
fever and the people really get sick
after injected being injected with the
bacteria e.coli and that's normal but it
was not normal to be able to inoculate
that reaction how did we do that by
breathing exercises that are like
controlled hypoxia where through the
brain stem the fight and flight suddenly
activates the adrenaline and resets the
body and resetting the body is going
past our comfort zone conditioning going
back in our primordial state the way
nature meant it to be and that is being
able effectively to battle this is very
simple very effective very accessible
for any human in the world and that we
go a step further a Stepford is the last
study wherein I was exposed to cold
water and just by a thought I was able
to make the skin temperature not going
down well I was exposed to cold water on
my skin ice water your skin temperature
didn't yes and normally it goes down
that is what everybody thinks isn't it
and yes 74 people before me they did it
and they saw all the same graphics it
goes down after exposure to cold water
and when warm water comes up then it
goes up again and goes down called walk
cold walk cold walk and then I did it
same I didn't do anything
why because I'm in command of my breath
and with that I become a in command of
my alchemy and I'm able then to scent
and to manipulate any part of my body
they looked inside the brain and whereas
normally as stress comes to work on the
body
and that could be called could be heat
but could also be emotion depression
bipolar anxiety fear PTA PTSD trauma
it's all stress in the brain and it gets
inflamed and we don't know how to break
the loop now they looked inside of my
brain while this stressor was gone on
and I stayed out of de-stresser
when the cold came in I just stayed over
there in a warmth cold wolf I stay in
control and then they looked inside the
brain and whereas normally the activity
of the stress is highlighting the
prefrontal cortex the conscious brain
because it's cold
oh I feel bad because I'm divorced now
and this and that and my business is
gone and whatever you know stress real
stress and then the insula which is
normally active very activated when you
go into deep meditation then the insula
gets a is becoming more rat and then
this is blue because deactivates the
normal daily consciousness and the
insula the deep meditation is own blood
flow goes in the deeper parts of the
brain something becomes all active and
its pleasant it's nice
before ik if you go into the eyes you're
really not thinking about your mortgage
or your wife or this or that you are not
going to picnic you feel the focus will
be on your feeling how to get this
feeling into adaptation and to overcome
whatever is coming and it goes directly
in a I tell you the the cold has been my
teacher I just followed the teacher the
feeling learned to let go intuitively I
felt I want to do this I did yoga did
come food that all kinds of things and
and great but the cold is really
merciless but righteous and I was ready
to go in I felt intuitively I want to
because it has got something I don't
know what it is and yes I went in and I
failed it the connection was there
beyond any word and that's what I was
looking for this tapping into deeper
part of the brain feeling pure energy
feeling our innate capacity the power we
have to deal with that I was looking for
that and since then I went on and on and
on and on I did all these records and
many more challenges I did crazy stuff
really sitting all the night in your
shorts outside in freezing temperatures
and feel great that is something that is
power and I've been venturing and
discovering more and more and finally I
began to realize but it's all in the
mind
oh yes so learning to let go in the
right way following your breath the
breath is able to prime the body and
then your mind the neurology of the mind
if I'm able to make my skin temperature
not going down well being exposed to ice
cold water skin temperature that's the
power and that power is the same power
we can learn to embrace and awaken in
which we are able to tackle any stressor
in the world any stressor emotionally
and physically and mentally whatever you
come up we are built to be able to
oppose that to get through and to learn
and not to be afraid because we have the
power of the mind it seems like there's
two things to your method number one is
the breath so what I want to know is
when you're breathing in the way that
you're breathing which there's a lot of
great video on there that will link to
in the show notes so when you're
breathing like that why do you think
that allows you to begin to reconnect to
something that everyone will call the
autonomic system meaning that you don't
have conscious control over how does
that link it yes a very simple these
breathing techniques I've learned to do
in extreme cold so
they are stream Li effective very soon I
was able to stay and prolong my time in
ice water feeling great but is the
breath just about oxygenating the
tissues oxygenating not only to go past
in this case to go past the lymphatic
knots which normally inhibits the oxygen
to go deeper now we found a way to go
past these knots into the lymphatic
system and with that you come into the
depth of your body and making you able
to alkalize you blood within a couple of
minutes and with that a when the blood
is the right pH degree then suddenly the
neurology of the mind which is like
electricity is able to run through on a
subtle basis so actually we are mammals
we are about you know we are built after
millions of years as mammals if your
geology is inside the wiring and
everything is inside and three times the
world's length is vascular systems
inside of us killer number one in our
society is cardiovascular related it's
big time and that is because we wear
clothes we are never being a stomach
stimulated through cold warm and
pressure it's no longer there so there
is a mediocre state of our vascular
conditioning and that and for that we
take cold showers then there's some
shock to the system that is haram Isis
or we do it consciously and with that we
connect even with the brain with the
vascular system all over and it's
amazing how simple it can be how simple
we contact tackle this serial killer
their cardiovascular related diseases we
can tackle in a cold shower a day keeps
the doctor away and rule number five the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is
breathe wimp each me some briefing right
now show me some so I can demonstrate it
alright you got a clock hey this says so
get get get me at a timer on you got it
right there I want you to go within two
rounds up to two and a half minutes
without air in your lungs no I can't do
that I can't this yeah you only die and
but then reincarnate come back as a guy
with this haircut oh no the last two
minutes you have to just press Start
okay so tell me what to do let let's do
just one round and about two minutes
without breathing you will stay I can't
without air in your lungs okay normally
we do this like four rounds in the
morning it takes about twenty minutes so
now we do one round about five minutes
is gonna take okay this'll be anybody is
able to do this along on a sofa or
sitting safely like you are sitting now
and orbit don't do this in water don't
they do is behind a wheels will of a car
because you really get into pasture
conditioning past your consciousness you
can go and there is nothing going on
it's great what is going to happen your
body becomes very alkaline which is just
newly being proven in a scientific
research be going to be published very
soon though is a lot related to this how
simple it is how many complications will
go away if you only do this let's go
right fully in free mouth huh yeah mouth
nose doesn't matter whatever you feel I
do like this
okay with your mind follow your breath
go on go on fill up your belly your
chest
everything you got boolean letting go
Fuli letting go we will do 30 30 breaths
we almost got 10 earlier
letting go relax
fool ya don't you let them fool in
letting go so all right fool yet let it
go
here is the meditation is the gong deep
even people meditating for years are not
able to go as deep as we will go now
angle go with the flow like the sea
waves getting to the shore then letting
go and there it comes again fully a
letting go 17 boolean let it go julio
letting go earlier letting go you feel
light in your head losing your body
tingling it's all alright breathe into
it
breathe into it intensified whatever you
feel is different we are charging off
the body we want to go into the depth we
are charging up the body
yes 23 7 more fully and let it go
oh yeah letting go fool yeah
poor fool yeah three boolean two boolean
one here comes the last one pull yet let
him go
and stop after the exhalation just
witness feel the feeling the rush it's
your blood then you nervous system
charge is there is no need for breathing
whatsoever it's no hypnotizing just a
magic of the physiology at work now we
are your body your nervous system is
getting into the brain step slowly and
surely oxygen levels begin to decrease
rapidly does the brain stem is beginning
to answer a there is no oxygen but you
are alkaline you chemistry is right so
there is no need for breathing but the
crocodile doesn't understand he says I
have to survive adrenaline shoots out
you get a reset to your primordial state
where in the immune system suddenly is
within the reach of the will and it's
happening all what is not necessary in
the body the wrong cells cancer cells
half cells it is being expelled because
you need to be in function a danger is
happening the body goes into this
autonomic nervous system state of being
to be the best of yourself and you are
doing it all consciously you are at ease
this is the way we get into the deepest
and take over control in the
neurological pathways right over there
blood flow is going into the depth into
all the parts of the brain any brain
scan is able to tell that so there it is
okay breathe in at breathe in and hold
and squeeze to your head
ten seconds ten nine eight seven six
five four three two one
let it go that is one round now this is
what these people did in the hospital
and then the bacteria had no chance how
simple it is and when we are dealing
with inflammation causing depression in
the end we take away the inflammation
with doing this within a quarter of hour
and people feel real revived of the
depression and depressed state so it's a
it's a cure for anything because we are
built to be able to prevent and heal
from disease both physical and mentally
and this is the way now I have a special
bonus clip with wim on how to go with
thin that I really think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go question number one
where do you need to take control in
your life for business number two how
are you not going to let the fear stop
you and number three how can you
schedule deep breathing into your daily
schedule and if you're gonna take
immediate action after watching this
video give me a hash
I believe down in the comments as well
life is no challenge if you just go with
the with everybody actually being played
with and for what for being to fit in a
system into daily life stereotypical be
go throught and path and never explore
something newly how how beautiful it is
if every day is a new day
opening up the cells to something you do
not control you do not understand yet it
is so beautiful I hope into esoteric
disciplines languages cultures religions
philosophies and all that couldn't made
that connection until I found myself in
freezing water one day in the morning
and the call really is merciless but
righteous it isn't feel cold at that
moment at all it felt like that this is
it a voice deep from within not from the
brain from deep within agreeing with
that moment came about engulfed me and
said that was the life that was the
connection
if you want to learn how to never get
sick using the wim HOF method check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there to me God is cold you
could say that I think of the cold as a
noble force